حياكم الله مشاهدينا الكرام اهلا بكم معنا
الى هذه الساعه الاخباريه المفصله تاتيكم
من العربيه
سريه لتجنب اتساع الصراع
مؤتمر المناخ يواصل اعماله في شرم الشيخ
والاضرار الناتجه عن الاحتباس الحراري
تتصدر المناقشه
وعط سعيد المتجدد في شبه الجزيره الكوريه
يونج
عسكريا حازم على تدريبات سولو واشنطن
وقبل يوم من الانتخابات التجديد النصفي في
الولايات المتحده الجمهوريون يتعاهدون
باستعاده الكونجرس
ايه ده مشاهدينا سنبدا وهذه الساعه من اخر
تطورات الميدانيه في اوكرانيا
جديده على البنيه التحتيه للطاقه في
اوكرانيا
اخرى على البنيه التحتيه وعلى مرافق
الطاقه في المقام الاول لهذا السبب احتاجت
روسيا صواريخ ايرانيه نحن نستعد للرد
جورج جورج
مستمره لكن رغم ذلك يتكبد العدو خسائر
فادحه هناك ورغم كل هذه الخسائر تواصل
روسيا الدفع بالمرتزقه والمجندين الى
حدفهم اشكر جنودنا الذين يتحملون هذا
الضغط الرهيب ويستمرون بصمودهم مدافعين
ببطوله عن مواقعنا
اهلا بك يا هاني معنا هاني ما هي اذن
التفاصيل الميدانيه في الساعات الاخيره
خصوصا هذا الحديث عن انه على ما يبدو
روسيا تحشد له هجوم كبير تحديدا خارجون
نعم خارج خرسون وكذلك في خرسون ولكن سوف
اتحدث في البدايه عن خرسانه التي الان
اطلقت القوات الروسيه نداءات لاهالي خلصن
الخروج منها قبل العاشر من نوفمبر اي بعد
ثلاثه ايام هي المهله الاخيره همم اذا ما
لم يتم الخروج من قبل المواطنين سوف يتم
ايضا همم فرض عليهم الخروج او القتال معهم
طبعا ايضا في الجانب الاخر القوات
الاوكرانيه تتحدث بان المواطنين هناك في
خرسون اصبحت القوات الروسيه تقوم بتعذيبهم
وايضا اي اصبحت القوات الروسيه بحسب حديث
الجيش الاوكراني ان تتخذ من الزي المدني
هي منطقه انتقال لهم من مكان الى مكان اخر
وحولت خرسون الى منطقه
حرب للشوارع هذا ما يحدثون اي اي ايضا في
المناطق الشرقيه هناك همم واضح جدا ان
اللغه الرئيس الاوكراني تغيرت همم من خلال
حديث بان هناك مرتزقه من قبل ايضا عناصر
في القوات الروسيه طبعا تداولت انباء
كثيره في الفتره الماضيه بان روسيا بدات
ايضا تقوم بتجنيد بعض المرتزقين من خارج
روسيا ايضا بدات ايضا همم هناك بعض
المناطق الروسيه بدات تاخذها كمنطقه
لجعلها كمنطقه منشيات وتجنيد بعض
الميليشيات طبعا هذه الانبا هي ما تتراوود
هنا في الاعلام او ما يتراويد في الاعلام
الاوكراني وايضا بعضها ما يتواجد في
الجانب الروسي هذا ما يتم همم الان في
المناطق الميدانيه والمسجدات الميدانيه
ايضا من خلال المسجدات على وجه المعارك
ايضا وفي المناطق الملتهبه الجيش
الاوكراني نفذ اكثر من 22 صار جويه خلال
الساعات الماضيه استهدفها من خلالها
انظمه مضاده للصواريخ وكذلك احدى المحطات
الخاصه بالحرب الالكترونيه وهذه لاول مره
يتم استهداف فيها محطه او احدى محطات
الحرب الالكترونيه والتي كانت تقوم بشكل
كبير من الجانب الروسي ولكن تعتمد عليها
خاصه في المناطق الشرقيه من اوكرانيا ايضا
هناك بعض المسيرات التي تم استهدافها وهي
تحديدا خمس مسيرات ولكن لم يتم تحديد
نوعها من خلال البيان الذي اصدر من قبل
الجيش الاوكراني عاده ما يقول ان هذه
مسيرات هي ايرانيه الصنع هل هذه المره لم
يتم توضيح نوعيه هذه المسيرات ما اذا كانت
ايرانيه ايرانيه او روسيه
الان بعد ان دخل الشتاء درجات الحراره
اصبحت متدنيه هناك استهداف لمحطات الطاقه
بشكل كبير في اوكرانيا
طبعا شرح ايضا في وقود كيف هي الحياه
وبختصار لو سمحت
نعم في 30 ثانيه سوف اتحدث اليوم عاده
الدراسه من جديد هنا الى اوكرانيا يبدو ان
هناك هاجس كبير بالنسبه للمواطنين اليوم
خاصه في ظل انخفاض درجات الحراره التي
وصلت الى درجتين مئويه اليوم سوف يكون
هناك مؤتمر صحفي لمدير مركز ابحاث الطاقه
الذي سوف يتحدث ايضا عن خطه لاجلها في حال
انقطاع التيار الكهربائي عن كيف ولكن ما
هي خطه هذه الاجازه سوف يكون سوف نتعرف
عليها في المؤتمر الصحفي الذي سوف يقام
فيه تمام الساعه الثانيه 10 والنصف بتوقيت
المحلي همم
شكرا جزيلا
مشاهدينا نقلت صحيفه عن مسؤولين امريكيين
قولهم ان المستشار الامن القومي الامريكي
او غيرها من اسلحه الدمار الشامل كما تهدف
الى تجنب مخاطر الصعيد وبقاء قنوات
الاتصال مفتوحه وليس مناقشه الوصول الى
تسويه للحرب
هذه نشره مستمره مشاهدينا وفيها بعد قليل
تظاهرات مستمره في طهران واحتجاجات شديده
في جميع شمال غربي البلاد
اهلا بكم من جديد مشاهدينا نفتح الان ملف
قمه المناخ في شرم الشيخ في مصر
اذا يتواصلوا توافق قاده العالم الى
المؤتمر الذي سيبحث لاول مره مساله تعويض
الدولي الفقيره الاكثر عرضه للتضرر من
تغير المناخ من قبل الدول الغنيه
110 من قاده دول والحكومات بمداخلات امام
المندوبين في شرم الشيخ هذه المداخلات
ستاتي على خلفيه ازمات او هي تاتي بالفعل
على خلفيه ازمه متعدده يشهدها العالم بما
في ذلك ازمه الطاقه مع تجدد الدعم لمصادر
الطاقه الاحفوريه وازمه الغذاء
طبعا مشاهدينا نتابع معكم الان هذه
اللقطات الحيه والمباشره لتوافق الزعماء
وممثلي الدول المشاركه في مؤتمر المناخ في
شرم الشيخ في استقبالهم طبعا الرئيس
المصري عبد الفتاح السيسي وايضا الامين
العام للامم المتحده انطونيو كوتيرش
اذا مازلنا مع هذه الصور الحيه لوصول
الوفود المشاركه ورؤساء الدول المشاركين
في قمه المناخ
هذه القمه تعقد في شرم الشيخ في مصر
وتاتي في وقت يتعرض هؤلاء القاده لضغوط
كبيره لتعزيز تعاهداتهم المناخيه ازاء
الاحترار او الاحتباس الحراري
وطبعا هذا الاحتباس ودرجات حراره الارض
اخده في الارتفاع بشكل كبير في العقود
الماضيه وايضا لاول مره سيتم الحديث عن
امكانيه دعم ماليه وتوفير دعم مالي الدول
الفقيره والتي ستكون هي الاكثر تضررا من
جراء الاحتباس الحراري
وتغير المناخيه ان يتم تعويضها ماليا من
قبل الدول الغنيه
قمه المناخ ستعقد نسخه ثانيه ايضا من قيمه
مبادره الشرق الاوسط الاخضر وهي مبادره
السعوديه تساهم في تسريع وتيره العمل
المناخي وتسلط الضوء على ابرز تحديات
المناخيه التي تواجه المنطقه وابعادها على
الصعيد العالمي النسخه الثانيه من منتدى
مبادره السعوديه الخضراء ستجمع هذا العام
نخبه من المتحدثين والخبراء وقاده الفكر
لتعزيز العمل المشترك لتسريع تحول نحو
الاقتصاد الاخضر وبناء مستقبل اكثر
استدامه للاجيال القادمه
لمعرفه المزيد معنى الامن مقر النقاط قمه
المناخ في شرم الشيخ مراسل العربيه احمد
عثمان اهلا بك يا احمد معنا احمد اذا ما
هي الاجواء من هم القاده الذين وصلوا حتى
هذه اللحظه وجدول الاعمال هذه القمه في
اليوم الثاني
لوسائل الاعلام وسائل الاعلام من جميع
انحاء العالم يتواجدون الان داخل هذه
القاعه لمتابعه اليوم الاول لاجتماع
القضاء امس كان يوم تسليم وتسلم وتم
الاعلان فيه عن كثير من النقاط التي تحدثت
فيها فيما يتعلق بما تم الاتفاق عليه يعني
هناك نبره من التفاؤل تسيطر هذا العام على
المتواجدون هنا في شرم الشيخ ربما لان
النقطه الابرز هي في النجاح في الوصول الى
نقطه التلاقي فيما يتعلق به مساله التمويل
مساله وضع على اجنده هذا الاجتماع
النقاش تعهدات من قبل الدول الغنيه والدول
المتقدمه لمساعده الدول الاكثر تضررا من
الدول الفقيره او الدول الناميه نحن نتحدث
عن الكثير من الدول التي اعلنت في احتياج
لهذه المساعدات ومنها دول القاره السمراء
على سبيل المثال وبالتالي هذه النقطه يعني
كانت حساسه جدا في الماضي وبالتالي حتى
كان هناك تحفظ على استخدام كلمه همم همم
تعويضات وتم يعني استبدالها بكلمه تمويل
لهذه الدرجه كان هناك ربما حساسيه في ما
يتعلق في هذه النقطه اعتقد بان هذا الملف
تحديدا سيكون محل النقاش ما بين القاده
واللي وضع اليه تنفيذ ربما البعض يتخيل
بان الحديث او الاحاديث من الايام قمه
مؤتمر باريس وصولا الى جلاسكو كان حديثا
هاما جدا ولكنه حينما ياتي الامر الى واقع
التنفيذ الى وضع اليات للتنفيذ تظهر
التفاصيل وتظهر المشاكل القائمون على
النسخه الحاليه من المؤتمر حريصون الى حد
كبير على تجاوز هذه العقبه والانتقال الى
وضع اليات للتنفيذ ابتدادا
طب من قبل رزق اهداف هذه القمه هو اجر هو
ااا يعني اتخاذ اجراءات جريئه وفوريه للحد
من الاحتباس الحراري الى اقل من 2 درجه
مئويه طبعا هذا الى جانب موضوع الدعم
للدول الفقيره الاكثر تضرنا من الاحتباس
الحراري ولكن فيما يتعلق بهذه الاجراءات
الجريئه والفوريه همم هذا الكلام ينادى به
منذ يعني سنوات هل نتوقع اجراءات او هل
هناك حديث عن اجراءات هذه المره مختلفه ل
همم حل المشكله الاحتباس الحراري
يعني احد يستطيع ان يتكل او يعطي بابهوى
ما سيتم الاتفاق عليه هذا الاجتماع من
المفترض انه يستمر حتى الثامن عشر من
الشهر الحالي بعد انتهاء كلمات القاده
اليوم وغدا وحتى وصولا الى كلمه الرئيس
بيدن الذي سياتي الى شرم الشيخ يوم الجمعه
المقبل في زياره ستستغرب ست ساعات هناك
مجموعه من ورش العمل والنقاشات المستفيده
التي سيتم الدخول فيها في كل هذه التفاصيل
ربما الاختلاف الابرز هذه المره او في هذه
النسخه عن غيرها من السابق كما ذكرتي هو
بالفعل الوصول الى فكره الاعتراف بانه يجب
ان يكون هناك تمويل او تعويضات للدول
المتضرره هو
كلفت الدول المتضرره ايضا مليارات
الدولارات لتتمركز الجهود خلال قمه المناخ
كما ذكرنا هذا العام حول امكانيه تعويضتها
انت يا كاتون بحقي لوحات عالميه او اغلاق
طرق ومترى ومطارات كلها اساليب يتبعها
البيئه مؤخرا للاحتجاج على ازمه المناخ
لتصبح محل الانتقاد العالمي
ازمه المناخ قضيه عادله الا ان اساليب
احتجاج ناشط البيئه تتخطى الحدود وتؤدي
الى العديد من الحوادث التخريبيه وصل
بعضها الى حادثه موت متظاهره في برلين تحت
عجلات شاحنه بعد ان اغلقت المظاهره طريق
العمل
اساليب متنوعه اتبعتها تنظيمات مدافعه عن
البيئه الفن كان الهدف الاول حالات تعدن
على لوحات عالميه تبلغ قيمتها ملايين
الدولارات
خاصه وطماطم تحول اللون الاصفر للوحه دوار
الشمس
الى الاحمر وبطاطا مهروسه تنساب على اكوام
قش كلود مونيه
واخرها لوحه ثاني للفنان الاسباني
فرانسيسكو ديجويه في متحف برادو في مدريد
تظهراني في مقطع فيديو وقد قام الرجل
وامراه من جماعه بيئيه بالصاق ايديهما
باللوحتين مع عباره تحمل الرقم درجه ونصف
مئويه وهي الحد المتفق عليه عالميا لزياده
في درجه حراره الارض وفقت اتفاقيه باريس
للمناخ في 2016
وبالتزامني مع انعقاد قيمه المناخ كوب 27
في شرم الشيخ تزايدت الاحتياجات البيئيه
بمختلف اشكالها ليتجمع عدد من الناشطين في
مطار في امستردام في مظاهرات نظمتها
في ملابس بيضاء جالسين امام عجلات
الطائرات يمنعوها من الاقلاع لساعات بحجه
ان المطار اكبر مصدر الانبعاثات ثاني
اكسيد الكربون بالرغم من ان المطار
يتطلعوه الى ان يصبح خاليا من الانبعاثات
بحلول عام 2030 الى عمر العربيه
عبرت الامم المتحده عن بالغ القلق من
تصعيد الاعمال الابتدائيه في ادلب شمال
الغربيه سوريا كافه الاطراف الى الالتزام
بجميع اتفاقيات وقف اطلاق النار وقد حضرت
الامم المتحده
يعانون من استمرار الاعمال الغدائيه في
شمال غربي البلاد مشيره الى توفيق ما لا
يقل عن 121 مدنيه بسبب الاعمال الابتدائيه
ننتقل الى مشاهدينا الى العراق فقد بلغت
الحصيله النهائيه لحريق مخزن الوزيريه في
العاصمه بغداد 32 مصابا بينهم مدير عام
الدفاع المدني وعدد من الضباط والمنتسبين
بحسبنا ذكرت وسائل الاعلام عراقيه
معانا لا مشاهدينا
عفوا معنا اذا من بغداد مراسل العربيه
منتظر الرشيد اهلا بك يا منتظر معنا منتظر
صف لنا ما الذي تشاهد وتم اخماد النيران
بحسب ما تحدثت الانباء ولكن مازال هناك
مفقودين ما هي السوره لديك
استمرت اكثر من نيعات ساعه بالتالي نحن
الان امام مرحله همم البحث عن مفقودين
يجري الحديث عن انه ما يزالون داخل هذا
المبنى الذي تشاهدونه الان هناك اليات
تابعه همم
للجيش همم استعانه بها قوات الدفاع المدني
من اجل همم البحث عن ناجين وازاله الانقاض
التي خلفها هذا الحريق عمليات تبريد حاليا
تجريها فرق الدفاع المدني تمهيدا لعمليات
البحث يدويا عن همم مفقودين يجري الحديث
عن انه ما يزالون
هناك تاكيد بانه في عدد من الاشخاص
موجودين كبيرين
نعم يجري الحديث عن وجود مفقودين وهذا ما
تعمل عليه فرق دفاع المدني في هذه الاثناء
هي تقوم بعمليه تبريد للمكان الذي شهد
الحريق ومن ثم ستبدا عمليات البحث عن
الناجين باستخدام طبعا همم وسائل مخصصه
لهذا الغرض يتجمع طبعا هنا فرق الدفاع
المدني العشرات منهم يتواجدون هنا بالتالي
العمليات التجري على قدم وساق منذ امس همم
وحتى صباح اليوم في ساعات مبكره تمكنت فرق
الدفاع المدني طبعا من اخماد الحريق بشكل
كامل ما يجري حاليا هو عمليه تبريد للمكان
الذي شهد الحريق وهو عباره طبعا عن مبنيين
متلاصقين كبير يستخدمونك مخازن طبعا
لتخزين
منتظر
يا ابني انا فقدنا الاتصال مع منتظر
الرشيد مشاهدينا لنا اعاده الاتصال سنعود
الى زميلنا في بغداد
على يد شرطه الاداب الايرانيه في منتصف
سبتمبر الماضي تزداد حده الاحتجاجات في
ايران يوما بعد يومين
جديده في جميع انحاء البلاد خصوصا في
الجامعات والمدارس كما لم تظهر اي بوادر
لتراجع المتظاهرين في ظل ارتفاع اعداد
القتلى والمعتقلين على الاحتجاجات في ظل
الغضب من قواعد اللباس السارما التي
اعتقلت امينه على اساسها لكنها تحولت الى
حركه واسعه نطاق ضد النظام الذي يحكم
ايران منذ سقوط الشعر النظام الايراني لم
يتوانى لحظه عن قمع المحتاجين واعتقالهم
شهدت حملات القمع توقيف نشيطين والصحفيين
وفنانين باريين غالبيه النواب الايرانيين
البالغ عددهم 290 بدورهم طالب بان تطبق
السلطه القضائيه العداله بموجب مبدا العين
بالعين واصفا لاحتجاجات بانها اعمل شغله
هذا وقد خرج تظاهرات ليليه في عدد من
المدن الايرانيه وخاصه في سندج وبشهر
وطهران وفيما جامعات شمال غربي البلاد
الغربيه الكرديه ايضا شهدت احتجاجات جديده
نشرتنا مستمره وفيها بعد قليل
الانتخابات التجديد النصفي للكونغرس
الامريكي
يحذر منها جماعه
في شرم الشيخ والاضرار الناتجه عن
الاحتباس الحراري تتصدر المناقشات
تصعيد متجدد في شبه الجزيره الكوريه
بيومين تتعهدوا برد عسكريا حازم على
تدريبات سول و واشنطن
قبل يومين في الولايات المتحده الجمهوريون
يتعهدون باستعاده
اهلا بكم من جديد
تعهدت كوريا الشماليه برد عسكريا حازم
وساحق ضد التدريبات العسكريه التي تجريها
كوريا الجنوبيه والولايات المتحده منذ
اسبوع الماضي
حربيه خطيره جاء هذا تحذير وسط سلسلتي
تجارب صاروخيه اجرتها كوريه الشماليه في
الاسابيع الاخيره بما في ذلك اربع صواريخ
بالستيه اطلقتي يوم السبت بعد ايامنا على
اختتام الولايات المتحده وكوريا الجنوبيه
اكبر تدريبات على الاطلاق للقوات الجويه
معنى لا مشاهدينا من واشنطن الخبير في
السنه الامريكيه والباحث السياسي عباس
اهلا بكم
ما الذي اثار حفيظه كوريا الشماليه هذه
المرات تدريبات عسكريه تجريها سول واشنطن
مشتركه منذ سنوات لماذا هذا التهديد
واستخدام كلمه همم عسكريه رد عسكريه هذه
المره من بيوم يعني
فرصه جيده جدا لكوريا الشماليه كي تظهر
قوه ثلاث سنتها العسكريه وقدراتها النوويه
وتستطيع ايضا ان تقوم باستخدام ما يحدث
اليوم من مناورات عسكريه بين واشنطن
الشغل
لتحديث الترسانه العسكريه لديها كوريا
الشماليه اليوم اصبحت لديها تجارب
بالصواريخ البالستيه التي تفوق سرعتها
سرعه الصوت وهذا تطور ملفت جدا لكوريا
الشماليه وهذا ما اعلن عنه خلال الساعات
الماضيه بسبب هذه الصواريخ بسبب هذه
التجارب
الصاروخيه الجديده وبالتالي همم كيم جونغ
اون كابيه وجده يعتقد بنفس الاعتقاد وهو
ان كوريا الجنوبيه بتعاونها المستمر مع
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه تشكل الخطر
الاكبر والداهم على كوريا الشماليه كوجود
وكان سياسه في منطقه متلاطمها وسياسات
فيها متغيره بشكل كبير
يمكن ان تفعل بيونغيانغ هل بالفعل ستقوم
بالرد بشكل عسكري وحازم وحاسم كما وصفته
ام انها كل هذه التصريحات تاتي في اطار
يعني الاستهلاك الدعائي المحلي الاعلامي
وتهديدات لاكثر
التهديدات
اكثر واا في ايطاليا الاستهلاك المحلي
طبعا بكل تاكيد يجب ان يكون دائما الشعب
الكوري الشمالي طبقا لرؤيه كيم جون جون
والقيادات في كوريا الشماليه مستعد دائما
لخوض معركه مع الجاره الجنوبيه او مع اي
غازي من الخارج وهنا تكون الولايات
المتحده كما يعتقد الكوريون الشماليون
كوريا الشماليه اليوم لديها اسلحه ولديها
صواريخ بالستيه تستطيع ان تصل الى همم
يعني الا العمقى الامريكي بمسافات تتراوح
بين 200 الى 500 او 600 كيلو متر داخل عمق
الاراضي الامريكيه وهذا ايضا تطور لكن هل
صواريخ كان قادره على ان تطير من كوريا
الشماليه وحتى واشنطن دون اي اعتراض هذا
هو السؤال الكبير الذي تعلم كوريا
الشماليه جيدا انها لم تستطيع القيام به
بسبب القدرات الدفاعيه الصاروخيه
الامريكيه
وبالتالي كل هذه تكون في اطار التهديدات
الاكثر وامريكا تعلم همم ان هذه تهديدات
بشكل كبير لن تكون همم موجوده على ارض
الواقع وامريكا لا تريد اصلا ان تدخل في
حرب مع كوريا الشماليه هي فقط تريد ان
تطوقها لكن بالاسلوب الخاطئ عن طريق اداره
جو بايدن وليس كما قام سلفه الرئيس السابق
دونالد ترامب الذي خطا اول الخطوات
الامريكيه داخل الاراضي الكوريه الشماليه
وكان قد بدا علاقه تبدو بشكل همم ما فيها
تفاهم بينه وبين كيم جون وكان من الممكن
ان تصل الى حلول افضل مما نشاهده اليوم
العسكريه هذه المره همم وصفت بانها اكبر
منوره جويه على الاطلاق تجريها همم كوريا
الجنوبيه مع الولايات المتحده همم ما هي
الرسائل من وراء توسيع نطاق هذه التدريبات
تصل الى ما وسخ بانه الاكبر على الاطلاق
المناورات الكبيره والكبيره جدا شاركت
فيها مئات الطائرات الحربيه وقطاع بحريه
مختلفه وبريه ايضا في هذا الاطار وتم
تدريب على
محاكاه العمليات صدر لاحتماليات غاز كوري
شمال لكوريا الجنوبيه او هجوم على قواعد
امريكيه همم طبعا هذه
العمليه تاتي في اطار همم يعني التوتر
الشديد الذي يعيش فيه الجنوب شرق اسيوي
اليوم المحيط هذا المحيط الكبير بسبب
التوترات ايضا بين الصين واا تايوان
والسبب ايضا قربها من التوترات روسيا
واوكرانيا فبالتالي الولايات المتحده
وهلفائها في هذه المنطقه دائما يريدون
الحفاظ على همم تفوق عسكري وتكتيكي
واستراتيجي بعد كل هذه انواع الرسائل التي
يجب ان يعلمها ما يصفوهم دائما همم
بالاعداء او على الاقل تقدير المنافسين
فالاستعدادات
عسكريه تاتي في هذا الاطار ل- اا تكون
دائما هذه التحالفات قائمه وواضحه لكل من
يحاول ان يخترقها بشكل او باخر شكرا جزي
لا والباحث السياسي ايهاب عباس
قبل يوم من الانتخابات لتجديد النصفي في
الولايات المتحده تعهد الجمهوريون
باستعاده الكاميرا في انتخابات منتصف
الولايه الحاسمه غدا فيما اصر ديمقراطيون
على انهم ما زالوا في المعركه قبل ساعات
على الاستحقاق ياتي ذلك في حين تستمر جهود
بعيدا وسلفه دعانا
الى صناديق الاقتراع في الانتخابات يوم
الثلاثاء حيث زارا باجن نيويورك
بعد تجمعاتنا نظمها الحزبان في ولايه
بانسانيه الرئيس الديمقراطيسه
جماعيته سر في شمال
تغذيه توقعات بشان اعلان وشيك عنترشحه
للرئاسه في عام 2024
هذه الانتخابات ليست استثناء بل انها
اختيار بين رؤيتين مختلفتين تماما لامريكا
لقد قلت منذ البدايه عندما خط الانتخابات
ان هدفي كان بناء اقتصاد من القاعده الى
القمه ومن المنتصف الى الخارج واقول لكم
انه تحول اساسي وهو ناجح مقارنه اقتصاديات
الشعار جعلوا امريكا قويه مره اخرى
في الانتخابات النصفيه
لا تتدخل في الانتخابات الامريكيه كما لا
تسمح بالتدخل في شؤونها داخليه واعتبر
رئيس مجلس الدومه هذه الاتهامات تبريرا
سباقيا من الحزب الديمقراطي لهزيمته
بعد اخطاء اداره
تحدث موقع نيوز ويك عن دلائل نظام الحزب
التقليدي في امريكا الذي يهيمن عليه
الجمهوريون
بالكامل تقريبا يمكن ان يبدا فيلم
فقط
بل قد يكون اول خطوه في طريق تراجع الحزين
التقليديه في امريكا التي يهايمن عليها
الجمهوريون والديمقراطيون بالكامل تقريبا
حتى وان كنا لا نسمع في اي مناسبه سياسيه
امريكيه سوى اسمين الجمهوري والديمقراطي
الا ان هناك جبهه اخرى تحارب سياسيا وهم
المستقلون فئه تعاظم عدد الناخبينها خلال
العقدين الماضيين فحسب استطلاعين اجرتهم
مؤسسه جالوب في سبتمبر حول الانتماء
الحزبي لوحظ تقدم للناخبين الذين يعتبرون
انفسهم مستقلين بنسبه 43% مقارنه بعام
2004 بنحو 27 بالمئه فقط ومع السياء
الناخبين من الحزبين الديمقراطي والجمهوري
برزات توقعات بزياده نسبه الناخبين
المستقلين فيما يقربوا من ثلاثه ارباع
الولايات عام 2035 ايضا بدات حظوظ
المرشحين المستقلين في التحسن
اون 84
قد لا تبدو رغبه المستقلين بالخروج من
عباءه حزب معين مستعجنا بالنظر الى كون
صراع الحمار الديمقراطي مع الفيل الجمهوري
يعود لقرابه مئه و 168 سنه ولا يزال
مستمرا حتى يومنا هذا بدا الصراع عام
1854 مع الرئيس الديمقراطي الرابعه عشر
للولايات المتحده
رئيس السادس عشر الجمهوري ابراهام لينكولن
الذي انتزع المنصبه من الديمقراطيين وبدات
معها مرحله التنافسي بين الحزبيين
وبعيدا عن حاله الصراع الداخليه بين
الديمقراطيين والجمهوريين يقف الناخب
الامريكي متخوفا من مصير ذلك التصدي على
مستقبل بلادهم حيث اظهر استطلاع راي اجرته
شبكته ام بي سي نيوز ان حوالي 80 بالمئه
من الديمقراطيين والجمهوريين يعتقدون ان
المعارضه السياسيه تشكل تحديدا وان عدم
وضع حد لها قد يدمر امريكا التي يعرفونها
بينما يؤكد ثلث الناخبين الديمقراطيين
والجمهوريين انهم ما زالوا يدعمون المرشح
السياسيه لحزبهم حتى ان كان ذلك المرشحون
لا يتوافقوا مع توجهاتهم
نقلت وكاله بلومبرج عن مصادر انا شركه
تويتر اتصلت بموظفين من من انها تخدمتها
خدماتهم بموجب خطه الملك الجديد
عن اخرين قبل ان تدرك الاداره ان عملهم
وخبراتهم قد تكون ضروري لبناء الميزات
الجديده التي
مشاهدينا هذه الان صور مباشره اذا من شرم
الشيخ لاستمرار وصول الوفود المشاركه في
قمه المناخ الكوب توينتي 7 كان عدد من
رؤساء الدول وصل على مدى اليومين الماضيين
ونرى طبعا كان في استقبالهم الرئيس المصري
عبد الفتاح السيسي
وايضا الامين العام للامم المتحده
الان طبعا رئيس الامارات الشيخ محمد بن
زايد الان اذا يصل الى شرم الشيخ للمشاركه
في فعاليات قمه المناخ كوب 27
ومع سياسه المحتوى في تويتر لن يكون هناك
تحضير ولا استثناءات مؤكدا ان اي تغيير في
الاسم سيؤدي الى فقدان المؤقت لعلامه
الاختيار التي تم التحقق منها
اعتبر وزير الاقتصاد الفرنسيه
ان السباق الى الاعانات مخالفه قواعد
التجاره الدوليه وانا المساعدات الامريكيه
للشركات تستدعي رضا واحدا وقويا من
الاوروبيين
بعض الشركات الاجنبيه الكبرى التي كانت
تريد ان تقيم او تقيم في اوروبا
تتراوح بين اربعه وعشره اضعاف في المبلغ
الاقصى الذي تسمح بتقديمه المفوضيه
الاوربيه
بدا ضغط الازمات الماليه والاقتصاديه
وتداعياتها الاجتماعيه في اوروبا يتسبب
برفض متزايد لموجات اللاجئين فقد ظهر سكان
قريه كلاك في غرب فرنسا ضد مشروع يقضي
بتوطين بضع عشرات من اللاجئين
واحده من العائلات التي ينص مشروع عمده
كالاك على استخدام المزيد من هائل البلده
لدمجها في المجتمع من خلال مهنه ما ربيعه
ومحمد سوريان كرديان من عين عرب وصل الى
هنا قبل عام مع اولادهما الاربعه قبل ان
تنقسم البلده حول استخدام اللاجئين
لبنان
على فرنسا سلمونا بيت الحمد لله البيت كل
شيء موجود بقلبه وفورا حط اولادي بالمدرسه
والحمد لله تعلم اللغه الفرنسيه وكله
مبسوطين منه المدرسين والانسات وانا
الضيعه اللي هاي اللي فيها انا باشكرهم عن
جد كلهم محترمين
باستفتاء حول استخدام المزيد منهم ويرى
بعضهم مدعوما من حزب استرداد فرنسا الذي
يتزعبه اليمين المتطرف
لهويه بلدهم عندما يذهب احد الى محطه
القطار سانشاغل في مارسيليا يلاحظ ان لا
احدا هناك يتحدث الفرنسيه
الى بلدنا عليهم ان يحترموا قيامنا على
بعد مئات الامطار تظاهره تدعمها قوى
اليسار راى مشاركون فيها ان استقبال
اللاجئين يغني ثقافه فرنسا وراى اخرون انه
يجب استقبالهم بشكل افضل
يجب ان نتحرك جميعا
الذين يطرقون ابوابنا هربا من الحرب
والجوع
من الطريقه التي عملتهم بها فرنسا يجب
استقالهم بانسانيه قبل ان تنفض التظاهره
المعاديه للمهاجرين انضم اليها شبان من
بينهم ملثمون راحو يهتفون فرنسا لنا قبل
ان تطاردهم الشرطه التي استخدمت الغاز
المسيله للدموع لمنع الاحتكاك بين
التظاهراتين
اذا الاولى مع فرنسا المنفتحه وضد الفاشيه
والمستعده لمساعده الذين يحتاجون الى
المساعده والاخرى تظاهره مع فرنسا
المتضامنه مع نفسها فقط والتي يخشى
المشاركون فيها من غزو يهدد ثقافه هذا
البلد وح طه والنموذج
العربيه من قريه كلاك غرب فرنسا
لقيا 24 شخصا على الاقل معظمهم طلاب جامعه
او مدارس حتفهم في غربيه
عند ما اصطدمت حافله بالشاحنه وفقا لحصيله
جديده الحافله كانت متوجهات من العاصمه
كوناكري الى فرنا في جنوب غرب البلاد قبل
وقوع الحدث قرب كنديه رابع اكبر مدينه في
غينيا وحتى الان لا يمكن التعرف على الجثث
بسبب درجه تشوههم بحسب مصدر في الشرطه
المحليه
قالت وزاره دفاع الصوماليا الجيش صده هجوم
نفذه مسلحونا من حركه الشباب على قاعده
عسكريه وسطر البلاد ولم تذكر الوزاره
تفاصيل حول طبيعه الهجوم وما اذا كان هناك
خسائر بشريه
تشتعلوا المعارك بين المسلحين القبليين
المدعومين من الجيش الصومالي ومقاتلي حركه
الشباب المواليه لتنظيم القاعده في عده
بلدات وقرن في اقليم هيران وصدصومال الجيش
الصومالي تحدث عن مقتل اكثر من 100 عنصر
من حركه الشباب في المعارك الاخيره
بالاقليم واستعاده بلدات وقرى
الاستراتيجيه تتوسع الرقعه المعارك التي
تشاركها احيانا طائره مسيره للقياده
الامريكيه في افريقيا دعما للجيش والقوات
المحليه قبائل بولايه الجنوب الغربيه
شومال تنضم الى العشائر الطائره وتقول
انها حمله السلاح لتحرير مناطقها من حركه
شباب التي تسيطر على مناطق واسعه من
الجنوب ووسط البلاد منذ 15 عاما
52 عاما واقسم بالله انني ساحاربهم جنتهم
محاربتهم هؤلاء يجب ان من مناطقنا
يؤكد مسؤول ولايه جنوب الغربي شومال انه
ولايته هم بعثت جزءا من الحرب الجاريه ضد
الحركه مشيرين الى ان المعركه في مناطقهم
ستحسم سريعا وحما ان توفرا
الى الصوماليين في اقليم جنوب غربيه
الصومال ليس امامهم سوى قتال عدونا
المتمثل في حركه الشباب قمنا بجوله في
مناطق عده بالاقليم لتعبئه الجميع لشني
عمليه المشتركه لقتلها هؤلاء وان نحظو
الاقاليم التي طردتهم
وتاتي هذه المعارك في وقت تعيش مناطق
عديده من البلاد حاله جفاف عاريمن يعد
الاسوا منذ الاربعين عاما عبد الرحمن
بخاري العربيه مقديشو
مهرجان العراق يقرا بدورته التاسعه توزيعه
70 الف كتاب من المختلف او من مختلف
الاختصاصات مجانا في بغداد مؤسسه محافظات
اخرى بهدف تشجيع على القراءه واستقبل وحب
ملحوظ للكتاب او للكتاب الورقي على نظيره
الالكتروني
هو طول مطالعه وعشاق القراءه متى ما
اضعتهم ستجدهم هنا بين الكتب المصطفى على
هذه الطاولات التي حملت بين دفيتها مئات
العناوين يقلبون اوراقها الى ان يجدوا
ضالتهم في تلك الصفحات
العراق لا يكتب فحسب بل انه لقب بالقارئ
النهم في دورته التاسعه ضمن فعاليات
المهرجان الذي انطلق من حدائق شارع ابو
نواس في العاصمه بغداد
تلك المبادره التي بدات منذ عام 2012 باتت
حدثا منتظرا يسقلب القراء والكتاب ما بين
متبرع ومشترن وموزع بالمجان المهم عدم
التوقف عن القراءه
في العراق
الموسم الموسم التاسع انه اقيم في سبع
محافظات في نفس الوقت
مع زياده على اقبال وتم سيتم توزيع 70,000
كتاب مجانا في عموم المحافظات السبعه اما
هذه السيده فتلقي متى يسر لها من نصوص
كطريقه لجذب انتباه محبي هذا النوع من
المؤلفات وايضا كاسلوب للتاكيد على ان
الكتاب الورقي مازال حاضرا رغم ان في
التكنولوجيا التي اوحت للبعض ان زمن
الاوراق ولا
نهائيا والدليل الاقبال الان وشوف شباب
صغار وشايلين الكتب وفرحانين بيهم وبعدين
القراءه بالكتابه بالجريده وبالورق انا
لها طعمها همم الخاص وهمم وتاثيرها يعني
الثقافه الشبابيه بين العراقين جدد عهده
بمضاعفه اعداد التوزيعات وحضور الالاف في
القراءه وعلى راي الكاتب عباس العقاد
وحدها من تعطي الانسان الواحد
اكثر من حياه واحده اسراء الصغير العربيه
سريه لتجنب اتساع الصراط
مؤتمر المناخي في شرم الشيخ والاضرار
الناتجه عن الاحتباس الحراري تتصدر
المناقشات
عسكريه
وقبل يوم من انتخابات تجديد النصفي في
الولايات المتحده الجمهور دون ان يتعاهدون
باستعاده الكونجرس
عربيه دوت نت دائما
مشاهدينا شكرا لكم